now a cave white coming up with a
temporary peace sacrifice Magnus raising
his eyebrows and the white Bishop there
is attacked so if Black's Knight was
captured White's light Square Bishop
would have dropped off and each giri he
must have hit Magnus Carlsen with this
opening surprise the world Champion's
slightly frowning he's confused black is
a piece up Bucky can't preserve his
piece that's extra night in the middle
of the wood will drop next he's about to
give up his Queen is that right Miss
Carlson has just giving up his Queen
what um he's gonna get three pieces in
return but look at this the Black Knight
I said it was pinned it cannot move it
stepped back capturing a bishop and then
white Bishop took a queen right now it's
a crazy imbalance white has Queen black
has a knight and two Bishops in return
so actually three pieces they add up to
nine a queen worth nine it is roughly
balanced a few moments later and uh here
he comes the pawn is closing in on its
destination and another check
look how this is just an exercise in
dominance now it's a queen on the board
and that's it game over Magnus Carlson
wins the